we've spent so much time as it relates
to a process that begins four weeks from
today did we mention it starts four
weeks from today went free four weeks
from today we focused so much on the
quarterbacks and chris i know that
that's a pet peeve of yours the the game
is driven too much by quarterback focus
let's focus on defensive free agents and
let's start with chris jones i don't
expect him to leave right especially
after the performance in the super bowl
they're not letting this guy get away
they'll tag him if they have to and
they're going to pay this guy what he
deserves i i would think so i mean first
off i i thought still like don't know if
we paid enough attention to that tweet
chris jones sent out when he said thanks
to kansas city fans you know and
whatever i got love for y'all whatever
it was he sent out you know that that to
me was a little weird that showed me
that maybe there's not a lot of talks
for a long-term contract yet because i i
do think that's got to be a real thing
right i mean i would think they're
thinking about paying my homes this off
season and getting out in front of that
chris jones is going to be in the
conversation for one of the high the
highest defensive player
paid defensive player in the nfl i do i
think he's going to be able to command
that type of contract so ultimately i
don't know if they're going to get to
that i'm with you i think the franchise
tag is a very real possibility for him
yeah and look the bottom line is you
want to get to the market to maximize
your earnings and even if they pay him a
long-term contract that you know takes
up a nice chunk of cash and cap space
it's not going to be as much as he would
get if he were on the open market could
you believe that this guy after the
performance we saw in the super bowl the
open market right it would be a record
for a defensive player right i mean he's
going to be it's going to be in aaron
donald land right i mean i know aaron
donald signed the contract two years ago
but that's what i would expect am i
crazy to think that i mean i would think
that he is going to command a khalil
mack aaron donald type of contract
are you with me there am i am i in crazy
yeah absolutely okay absolutely because
look both of those guys did not get paid
on the open market
aaron donald was under contract with the
rams and the bears had to give up all
that draft capital before they paid
khalil mack i said at the time they paid
khalil mack if they were able to get him
on the open market without having to
give up multiple first round picks they
may have given him 30 million a year
right so if chris jones had found a way
to the open market and the only way he
could do it as a practical matter is to
uh you know ride out the franchise tag
year to year and it's harder for a
non-quarterback to do that because of
the injury possibility for a defensive
player you know they're going to make
him an offer that's going to be far more
than he ever thought he was going to
make in the nfl but it's going to be
significantly less than he would get on
the open market shaq barrett is the next
guy we need to talk about he was the pft
defensive player of the year led the
league in sacks on a one-year deal with
the tampa bay buccaneers he said not
that long ago chris that he's willing to
take less to stay in tampa because he's
very cognizant of state income taxes he
doesn't want to play in california where
he got to give 13.3
to the government off the top of your
earnings so i think the bucks are going
to have a chance to keep him but they
may have to use the franchise tag on him
before they even get to the point where
they're working out a long-term deal
well yeah they might have to do that i
mean first off it's r the bucks have a
ton of money in the salary cap so they
should be able to pay a guy like this
you know shaq barrett i think should be
able to command big money but because
it's only
it's a kind of a one-year unicorn year
right i don't think he's going to be
able to demand money like we just talked
about like a chris jones or some of the
other top-tier pass rushers on the list
but it's unique of the guy like this
flying under the radar as the nfl sack
leader and i would think this is the guy
the bucks would want is the guy that you
can build around you know and you talk
about culture and a guy that's buying
into everything they're doing i think
that fits and i would imagine they find
a way to keep him and sign him to a
long-term deal and just figure out the
right number going forward
yeah i think you're right and uh i think
the the buccaneers as bruce erin's head
coach of the team has made clear
in some of his recent conversations with
the media the idea that uh
we have to keep our defense together
yeah it's not just about who the
quarterback is going to be and they're
trying to make that defense better and
better the seahawks made their defense
better last year with davey and clowney
he was dominant at times that monday
night game against the 49ers that was
arguably the best game of his career
then he had that that issue with the
sports hernia that kind of derailed the
rest of his season right the seahawks
want to keep him
and and i did the deal is set he can't
be tagged he's going to be one of these
high-end defensive players who hits the
open market
what do we expect the demand to be for a
guy who has been more potential than
production yeah for most of his career
yeah i mean yeah that's fair to say now
again you know that you know uh he's in
the top of the list as far as f the play
up type of player right and the
production doesn't always match the
disruption he causes
the thing with you clowney and of course
the seahawks have great knee jokes
the thing for jacloni okay is they need
the position desperately it's imperative
to the way they play football and their
defensive scheme right it's the 49ers
seattle seahawks defensive scheme pass
rushers are huge clowney's a huge talent
but injuries are a concern can you
really sit there and go i'm going to
give 60 million guaranteed to deviant
clowney you know there's knee issues
there's the hernia issues he plays such
a physical brand of football so you know
i think there's going to be great need
for him but i think where it's going to
be weird is there's going to be a lot of
i think short-term contract offers for
him i don't think anybody's just going
to give him a huge pool of money and go
you're our guy for the next five years i
think he's a guy that's probably gonna
have to earn it every two or three years
because of his injury history and the
way he plays
yeah i think you're absolutely right
it's going to be a one or a two year
thing it's going to be what will happen
if there are ever across the board
guaranteed contracts in the nfl and
maybe that's not a bad thing for the
players there will be a lot more
movement there'll be shorter contracts
if every deal is going to be fully
guaranteed and that may be what someone
has to do with javian clowney or jaclony
as you just called it and free agency in
20 20. yannick and gawkway look he's a
guy who has been jostling for a contract
with the jaguars another great pass
rusher franchise tag available for him
as well wants that deal uh and i you
know imagine if
if these guys actually were all getting
to the market i think that that uh you
know jones barrett and likely and
gawkway are gonna get tagged but uh
he's another guy that has proven that
that he can get it done he's the guy who
became for jacksonville what dante
fowler jr was supposed to be yeah right
well and you know his stats you know if
you want to look at that and go off of
that right and you talk about production
and all of that stuff you know they're
better than demarcus lawrence with the
dallas cowboys who signed a 100 million
dollar contract so yannick and gawkway
is going to be able to command that type
of money he's that type of player this
year is going to be unbelievable for
this position in free agency there is a
just if anybody gets to the market if
they any of you're right i mean that's
the thing there's a lot of teams with
this positional need there really is and
if yannick and gaque can get to the
market he is going to crush it i mean
gosh the tennessee titans need it the
jacks i mean the the indianapolis colts
those are two teams in their own
division they put you know the
they're gonna want guys like yannick and
goku the seattle seahawks that we just
talked about they play the same scheme
the jacksonville jaguars play that
seattle scheme they're going to be in
demand so yeah i don't know where it
goes and he's probably going to get
franchised too you're right
but man i'm just amazed about the names
as far as the pass rusher quality and
the teams that need pass rushers and
then a lot of them have money to make it
happen that's where it's going to be a
lot of fun to watch and yannick's going
to be able to command big money if he
gets there you're right that's why i
don't like this i'm sick of the
franchise tag thing screw off franchise
tag
you know every july we see football
players complain about the money that
basketball players we've never heard of
get in nba free agency right i think the
more appropriate complaint and i think
this is one of the things we've seen
play out when a guy who got franchise
tagged sees somebody who is a lesser
player hit the market and strike it rich
yeah and you know we could see that like
how about an eric armstead like
the 49ers franchise guy who had nine
sacks in four years combined yeah ten
sacks in a year where he had nick bosa
and d ford attracting attention are they
going to think they can plug somebody
else in that spot or are they going to
tag eric armstead he could be the guy
who gets to the market he could be
and barrett and jones are looking at
saying what the hell this guy has his
lottery prize not that it's not an
unearned lottery these guys deserve
everything they're getting but the way
the system's set up you can have guys
who are getting more than maybe they
should in relation to better players who
are held in place by the tax a hundred
percent i i just i don't like the
franchise tag i don't you know you talk
about the draft being un-american to me
the franchise tag is like as un-american
as it gets i mean that's communist is
what that is all right so that bothers
me and your your point is very real and
you know as far as the eric armstead
thing i don't know you know again where
the 49ers have some balancing to do with
their their balance sheet as far as
money is concerned and yeah i would
think they'd want to franchise him to
keep that defense aligned together but
they got not a lot of money in the
salary cap they got to try to pay jimmy
ward who's one of the better safeties in
all of football kyle use check we know
how important he is to that offense in
that team they got to pay him too they
traded away a second round pick for
emmanuel sanders i have a hard time
believing they'll just let him walk out
the door quite yet so that one is going
to be interesting to me and you're right
i think that's the one i first look at
here to go i think he will hit the open
market uh because i think the 49ers have
some other issues as far as their roster
is concerned
look i my attitude on the franchise tag
is somewhat complicated i i accept the
fact that it's not going anywhere but i
agree with you
i don't like it and the the best
evidence that the franchise tag is not a
good thing for players the owners can
still want it
they still want it but let me go back to
the early 90s the anti-trust lawsuit
filed by reggie white and others that
culminated in a settlement agreement
that created real free agency right the
franchise tag was part of it but for the
guys who put their names on the lawsuit
the franchise tag could never be used on
them that tells you that the franchise
tag is not a good thing right or uh it
would have been applicable to the guys
who put their names on the lawsuit that
sparked this whole free agency process
and it won't be true free agency until
the ability to arbitrary not arbitrarily
you're strategically holding a guy
in place on a team who otherwise would
hit the market and make a ton of money
and stretch the rubber band for everyone
else yes uh
that's that's where it just absolutely
drives me crazy it does and then also
you know the same thing you probably
heard me say this before i mean you know
what what what what profession is this
happening hey
you're the best of your profession in
the whole world but we don't quite want
to give you anything guaranteed or show
you any you know future or anything yet
we're going to make you roll the dice
one more year to make sure you're still
the best profession in the world at your
job and you know if you mess up well man
that price is going to go way down way
down now if you do really good maybe
you'll make a smidgen more it's it's
just bs i don't know what else to say
about it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports